[Musique]
c'est en ce premier jour de printemps
que le château de versailles tourner
enfin la page de la tempête un jeune
tulipier de virginie a été replanté
aujourd'hui identique à celui rapporté
au xviiie siècle par le général la
fayette est abattu en décembre dernier
par les intempéries
un tulipier qui prendra racine au même
emplacement une cérémonie volontairement
symbolique autour de l'amitié
franco-américaine
les américains sont terriblement attaché
à versailles et dès qu'il y ait cette
tempête j'étais aux états unis au moment
de la tempête c'était extraordinaire la
solidarité quatre élèves de l'école de
fayetteville en géorgie qui a financé
l'achat de cet arbre était présente aux
côtés d'une représentante de la maison
blanche et d'une entreprise américaine
mécène de l'opération qui offre 100
arbres au parc de versailles
c'est vraiment fantastique dans 51 je
pourrais venir ici avec mes petits
enfants et leur dire quand j'avais votre
âge et planter cet arbre à versailles
c'est vraiment magnifique
l'europe a une unité américaine a offert
une centaine d'arbres notamment des
essences rares qui avaient des armes qui
étaient donc qui avait été importée à
l'origine par le général la fayette
était venu ici qui ont été détruites
la campagne de restauration du parc de
versailles a donc commencé chacun peut à
son tour parrainer un arbre et aider au
reboisement
[Musique]
hambourg a été élu président du conseil
général
sans surprise le président sortant du
conseil général des yvelines a été
reconduit ce jeudi matin dans ses
fonctions par 29 voix contre 1 vote
blanc et 9 abstentions celles de
l'opposition
franck borotra a détaillé son programme
pour ces trois dernières années de
présidence
un programme ambitieux à la fois en
termes d'investissements dans le domaine
dans le domaine social au travers de
l'insertion dans le domaine de
l'environnement en direction des enfants
les trois ans qui viennent vont se jouer
dans un contexte très différent parce
que d'abord ça va être la
décentralisation qui va donner des
pouvoirs ou des compétences
supplémentaires aux départements qui va
falloir assumer intégrer et gérer
décentralisation oblige le poids social
va s'accroître avec la prise en charge
par le département du rmi et une plus
grande autonomie fiscale
mais le président l'a souhaité il n'y
aura pas d'augmentation d'impôts ni de
l'endettement
il a à la fois fait le bilan de ce qui
avait été fait dans ces trois dernières
années a annoncé des lignes force forte
dans le domaine social dans le domaine
financier des investissements
il ya des choses sur lesquelles on se
retrouve il n'en reste pas moins que
dans ce département il nous sommes dans
des secteurs notamment dans le domaine
social il serait nécessaire de faire
beaucoup plus dans le domaine scolaire
peut-être dans certains cas les plus
loin notamment en matière sociale et
puis au plan économique aussi
et l'aménagement du territoire comme il
l'a dit autre sujet de discussion dans
les travées du conseil général la
succession de franck borotra élu depuis
dix ans il a réaffirmé qu'il s'agissait
là de son dernier mandat en lice pour
lui succéder
pierre bédier revenu au conseil général
après avoir été secrétaire d'état
aujourd'hui deuxième vice-président et
surtout président du groupe majoritaire
mais franck borotra préfère ménager le
suspense il ya de la concurrence il ya
de la qualité
il ya de la valeur à chacun de faire la
preuve de sa compétence et et de
l'intérêt qu'il peut représenter pour le
département une déclaration mi chèvre mi
chou comme dirait le président borotra
prochaine séance publique au conseil
général le jeudi 8 avril
[Musique]